hello welcome back to Shadows
overloathing I am here to play more of
it also
I am uching and I'm owing just minorly
but I'm uching and I'm owing
so that's what I'll get into the why of
that in just a moment
the air conditioner broken here so it's
probably going to get extremely warm
um I don't think I'm going to be able to
finish it but I did want to play this
uh because it has been way too long
since last I I played it and if I tried
to do it
um
by recording it it would just take way
too long because this game is very very
long hello hi hello everybody uh welcome
back
um we're gonna play Shadows overloathing
because I am extremely behind I'm
extremely extremely behind on this I
went I meant to get a lot more of this
recorded before I went off for Christmas
break
but I didn't also yes
I'll tell you why in just a moment but
reach out I'm uching and I'm ouching
um yes what about the title
look it's fine welcome everybody we're
gonna play shadows overloathing in just
a bit
um and we're going to get as far as we
can we're gonna get as far as we can
into oh that's
no that's fine
no that's good
no no no no no this bam there we go
so we're gonna get as far as we can
um but
we'll see what we actually get there I'm
not going to get demonetized it's
censored it's it's uh you don't know
what that stands for it's just
[Laughter]
look it's fine guys it's fine don't
worry about it no there's nothing there
it's it's censored so you have no idea
yeah yeah cookie
um
I'm like that anyway so just today and I
get my knees banged up here too if I
could get my knee in frame
uh so I Wang doodled myself
uh
I'm not sure [ __ ] key is a thing
um but you uh you fill in the blank with
however you want uh so yeah uh for those
of you who don't know uh
uh super 73 was kind enough to give me a
free bike now I'm not blaming them
it's not what I want people to think
um but I it's been raining a lot here in
Los Angeles and I went out for a ride
this morning just to go get some
groceries and on the way back in
um
there was this uh lady walking her dog
and it was right around a blind corner
so I was going
I was going right around the corner
and
I was uh going pretty fast but it's
electric bike so I can't I'm not like
flying too fast but I decided to Swerve
out a little more but because it was wet
in this particular Road was slanted a
bit I done my bike landed on my knee and
hip my hips pretty bruised up my knee is
pretty scratched up my bow got
scratchied a bit and I don't know if you
can see it but I apparently popped a
blood vessel in my eyeball I think you
might be able to see if I'm looking
there but maybe maybe you can maybe you
cannot but if you can there's something
exploded in my eye
but I am fine otherwise it doesn't hurt
bad at all doesn't hurt at all
so
anyway
it's time to get in no no not motorcycle
it's a bicycle it's an electric bicycle
I haven't I haven't ridden a motorcycle
in many years like I got rid of my
motorcycle a long time ago my eyes
I don't know if that's possible
stop getting hurt that's not well I
don't keep getting hurt well named the
last time I got hurt
mm-hmm
name it name the last time that I got
hurt you don't even know you're just
assuming things you don't know anything
anyway we're gonna do Shadows
overloathing and I'm going to do this
it's already getting boiling hot in here
I literally just got back and it's
already starting to get roasty toasty in
here and I swear to God I
this freaking air conditioner got
installed
literally before I left and then when I
came back it just stopped working it was
so wonderfully comfortable for such a
very short period of time and then all
of a sudden it decided to dick all over
the place and break so I I'm only
assuming that this is a result of that
because how could it dare do that to me
it's so warm in here it's so warm it's
so incredibly warm
I think I have to go open the door
but you guys know what happened last
time I opened the door
yes you think my arm is not too loud if
anything I'm too quiet
the air conditioner is not too loud
because it's off
because it's not working recap what I've
done okay for those of you who haven't
been watching religiously on these
you'll know that I have been exploring
and doing pretty much nothing in
accordance with the actual game but what
I have been doing is I've been getting
progress in terms of going back and
forth in time I made out with my past
and or future self I
fished I think
I'm pretty sure
that's it so where I am whoa
another one of those time doors let's
hope that repeated exposure to these
isn't going to give your ancestors
cancer I might go through it anyway oh
Crystal dream Dam construction all right
I forgot I had the big
show look there's no spittoons over here
there's no spittoons because uh that was
in the other game and I'm dancing for
some reason I can't go past
the edge of this window
to the past all right fair enough
let's see doors being delivered uh pipe
shoes
probably not what they meant to order I
got pipe shoes these don't make any
sense you're gonna just have to roll
with it
uh
okay I'm gonna see pipe shoes
I don't think they give any particular
wait there's a sound
[Music]
so the uh uh I don't know how pipe shoes
make you roll up in a ball
um but that's just what it is
I'm not sure if that was sarcastic but I
just thought haha LOL so funny and I'm
like that sounded so sarcastic and I'm
like oh look it's not the funniest thing
in the world but it's it's it's it's
kind of funny some careless damn worker
has abandoned in toolbox here their loss
is my game you gain some tools piece of
scrap metal and an 11 in one oil
did not get one of those before
give your targets shielded
man I don't
how about
how do I fit all right whatever now you
don't want to get your hook stuck damn
it
but I kind of do
but I kind of do
why would you even give me the t's oh
hey Noel says nobody who ain't on the
cruise a lot on the site Noel yeah Noel
the foreman Noelle white oh geez the man
clutches his stomach are you all right
to starving is all rest of the crew went
to lunch but somebody had to stay keep
all the rubber neckers out of and lookie
lose off the site I drew the short pants
short pants do you mean straw nah we've
got these six little pairs of pants we
found when we cleared out a nest of
fairies
I see can I have one
no because then we'd have no way of
picking who Stan's guard oh man I can't
believe how hungry I am feels like I'm
gonna turn inside out what about that
table over there that says lunch there's
a reason everybody else left the site to
eat pal you don't want to eat what Noel
considers lunch how bad could it be man
I'd kill for a jelly deal Noel brings
these sandwiches that are just a bunch
of peppermint sticks between two big
Bland sugar cookies you can get a
stomach ache just watching someone else
eat one sounds awful that's because it
is awful
why would I fight him why would I fight
him
why would I fight him why in the world
would I fight him
a handful of creams
cream first break roll a glocklin bro I
have a lot of
food how about a fresh baked roll
oh wow thank you he greedily devours it
his stomach is still growling uh cream
cheese
oh wow thank you uh he's starting to
look a little less hungry and a little
more relaxed
sardines
if you had to describe his current move
you'd probably say he's 60 sleepy and 40
hungry
oh this is all my food oh well thank you
but he he still looks just a little bit
hungry well this is all my food you know
I scone my food he slumps to the ground
and falls asleep oh
you stole all my food this son of a
[ __ ] I hate him I hate that man the
sign says lunch but what's on the table
isn't identifiable as anything you'd
want to eat claxman screws Grafton nuts
Daxton shafts Waxman discs Braxton
courts Frampton picks glaxton valves
that's that thing I needed
I forgot about that it's a brand new 11
year old glaxton valve
oh good good thing I got here when I did
what's that gonna do to the Future
though
seems awfully inconvenient
uh all right
fish
please
surprise it's full of water
you should leave the rest for people who
need I got a handful of clean water
okay
uh flush it
why does flushing toilets give me XP
that is that has been happening for
quite a while now
look why is that my type look it's just
a title of a video look guys it's just a
title it got you here that's all that
matters it's not the point the focus on
the content they're in that we're
watching here and then you can all
flabbergast about about whatever
nonsense the title is you're filling it
in with your dirty minds don't let your
dirty minds infect my family friendly
stream you're the problem not me you're
disgusting horrifying tainted brain is
not my problem
I'm here just to feed men from the past
and scoop up handfuls of water hey I got
a glaxton valve
I thought I knew a lot of hobo code I
guess I don't all right replace it
you've gone through too much for this
stupid valve to just give it to the
government oh
all right
hey there's a flower
smells as good as it looks that's nice
nasty goo okay
classic valve grab it this valve is had
in place by Decades of corrosion even if
you could datch it it'd be wrecked in
the process
uh-huh has been fished of all life did I
do it leave this damn thing behind very
funny
right I needed to bring a glaxton valve
somewhere yeah cookie
yeah cookie that's all it is and cookie
is definitely not a euphemism for
anything I doubt anyone here could come
up with a euphemism for whatever cookie
could stand for that would be unfamily
friendly so don't all you be the way
that you is let me be the way that I am
and I'm gonna whatever hello and it did
next to the dirt road you're walking
down you spy a pile of coal mine
tailings it must have fallen off a truck
or something you remember your history
of Rock's Professor telling you that you
could extract a little bit of hair
grease from
this stuff if you really put some elbow
grease into it
I got style let's chill
I'll never be as cool as a slime
says you
look I I knew to go to the lighthouse
look I say things out loud usually I
don't do this with an audience and I
know it seems counterintuitive
considering that most of my videos go
out to an audience of many many people
but I don't usually do this with an
audience when I need your help I'll ask
for your help when I say I don't
remember that's just my brain going
through the incredibly complex
algorithms that I know what to do
well you've got perversion dominating
like 60 of your brain I've got
intelligence okay all right can I do
some cookings
[Music]
I can make toast with stylish gel
I don't know if I want that
record douches pie
[Music]
I'll hold on to this I'm never gonna use
anything because I'm not gonna I'm Never
Gonna Wanna Do Anything
the Lighthouse Keeper confirmed talk to
him hi hello
I got the valve you asked for did you
install it no I have it right here won't
do as much good in your hands like that
go hook it up to the pump outside well
fine
screw you all right fortunately the
place where it slots in is clearly
labeled well all right then
good for me
I did the damn thing I installed it no
I've been watching the water level
through the window here should be dry
enough for our purposes now come
upstairs
okay
ah bulbs mind
you only use 60 watt light bulbs don't
need much ain't that big a lake
I what did you miss absolutely nothing
just chop being perverted fools and me
being a really Smart Genius person
that's all it is and not getting
demonetized that's definitely not What's
Happening Here
well here we are welcome to where the
magic happens magic sure
via Lu
Ed light housekeepers judge does anybody
get out on thing can I have the compass
well what no certainly not I need that
but you asked if I had an old compass
and I said I did and I'd show you I
never said nothing about giving it to
you well I really need it so do I I
gotta calibrate this lamb to the North
Star every so often and I need a good
Compass to show me which one is the
north one
what if I give you a new one nope I said
a good one the new ones ain't any use at
all why not because of how they changed
them
why
why they didn't teach you that in school
folks got a short memory it was only
around about the turn of the century
some Atlas company bought the patent on
West and repented
then they did a recall on all the
compasses and issued new ones they all
Point West now
okay how about I find you another old
one
if you can find another pre-new north
compass in at least as good a condition
as mine then sure I'll swap you don't
really get what the point of that would
be though since you already have one
well it's a it's a long story never mind
then
maybe this will help you most of the old
compasses got radium paint on the dial
so you can read them at night this whole
geiger counter ought to be able to pick
up the radiation from then
oh man this is really round about okay
ah most folks consider the old kind of
compass to be trash nowadays and if I
was trash it'd probably be at the old
junkyard neat thanks
an empty and wet bookshelf good thing he
had his books downstairs
Unsinkable Molly buttons shoots you a
wink
all right whatever
all right let's just go find a goddamn
Compass because I seem to be
being taken for a ride no matter which
way I go
yeah you know you guys I just look over
at chat sometimes and I just think to
myself wow how lucky am I that of all
the audiences I could have gotten on
YouTube I get you guys I'm just
I'm so lucky I'm so goddamn lucky that I
just look over at all I see is Bust A
Move bust a cookie bust a cocky busted
look cookies too loud
yep thank you guys thank you for being
here also where's my pity points did you
guys are here I crashed my bike and I
crashed it super hard out
do you see the blood you see the blood I
dressed my wounds myself and my hip is
bruised but I won't show you that I'm
not going to show you that and also my
eye exploded
you guys see that yeah thank you
the pity is too low
hey
I just hate you ever hate
you guys ever hate and find that I'm
hating him and my hate is very strong I
don't know that's why
I can't bust a bike I did bust my butt
and it was the new bike it was the new
bike
like a fragrance spores I don't want to
know why I was my new bike it was the
free bike that super 73 gave me that I
did not promote at all
man I'm bad about those kind of things
but they gave it to me for free in case
I so that I could promote it because I
do like my super 73 super 73 it's a good
bike uh but I smashed it up
it's all scraped up now very sad ooh a
heating heated fishing rod Cooks the
trash from the inside
oh
that's very nice the trash is left
medium rare but a connoisseur would eat
it Well Done of course they would I
don't want to know about that
geiger counter oh that's what's clicking
okay
um
the rod is almost too hot to handle I
mean
it's nice but it's not the same as my
garlic press does more maybe if I
actually had an enemy that I cared to do
the actual damage
all right there's something shiny oh wow
brain coral ring a ring card from a
chunk of endangered Coral mind melt also
increases your mysticality by three whoa
oh
oh banish is wandering Shadow creatures
that's pretty I feel like that's useful
oh God
I just see I look over at Chad just just
people have devolved from saying bust at
anything to just bust it's just blast
blast hip thrust bust bust a blood
vessel bust
laughs
I just wish you guys could see this from
my perspective of How It's like training
a terrible AI model that interprets what
chat could be but if anyone tried to
train it off what you guys are doing it
would just be complete nonsense more
than what you're doing actually it might
make more sense who knows
uh
uh a pile of trash must be especially
appealing to flies okay good
oh wow trash smells much worse than the
other piles do I have any
I don't think I have any stench armor
yeah I'm pretty sure I don't
I got two there
I don't think that would be enough
you'd think because it's a freaking gas
mask but whatever I guess not get my
mind God damn Fedora back
oh hi sir how are you hobo is trying to
wrestle a stove out of a pile of trash
howdy I'm beanie hi beanie I'm Mark what
are you up to I'm trying to get this
stove so I can haul back to our hobo
camp
I'm really weak my dude I'm really weak
I can't ask him about hoboko do you know
anything oh thank you thank you
uh
I don't even know what my muscles at my
muscles too
oh
I'm so weak I'm so wimpy why am I so
wimpy
hey I can get three physical armor holy
crap give me that how do I get that oh
how do I get that can I have that
I already got that
I'm really dumb
I already bought it that's why it's
highlighted I'm extremely stupid I'm
sorry everybody
I'm very dumb
um
I'll wait I don't care
hmm sleaze armor God damn it with all
these things the things that I need I
don't
I don't have any other sleaze armor this
is baloney all these things are saying
that I need things to be able to thing
them I don't have the things that
necessary to make the things so I can't
do anything
I can't do anything at all
what's a buster oh it's bust backwards
God damn it I can't
I can't look I thought I had 80d
you can just make it seem so much worse
there are a lot of fairies in that
direction flitting around giggling
maniacally and occasionally saying
things in other people's voices that you
can only assume with those people's last
words oh my God
what
oh hi oh oh what happened
why did everyone explode all right
whatever you guys have
you seem to be very tough
I'm concerned of my ability to survive
this
oh God okay you're gonna okay you're
gonna hit me you're gonna shoot three
random opponents you're gonna jab Grady
the ren okay you're fine
oh you're gonna explode the fairy
exploder
what do you mean what do you mean you're
gonna explode
well I guess that means you're gonna
die
but you I can take out with one go of
this nonsense here
you're dead now look at this the fairy
wackadoo
okay so it's either gonna heal everyone
on the battlefield for six or deal six
damage to them well it'll deal to you
your team as well right I guess that's
that's fine
that's fine are you gonna are you gonna
explode like to death
are you gonna explode like all the way
I hope so because I can't kill any of
you except for this guy and maybe that
one
man this is the part that I would
normally cut out but it's gonna you're
gonna explode bust the exploding fairy
that doesn't make any sense
bust the ferry bust and explode bust the
world the bust of 87.
yeah you're right how could I be so
stupid
um kneecap no I just shoots
well that did nothing am I gonna die
oh I'm gonna die no not my kneecaps
oh
okay we're fine
um I can heal myself
that's nice
focus at the mokus perfect
okay perfect
I don't know how the garlic press do
that but it definitely do fairies are
busting busted kneecaps bust my kneecaps
my kneecap is already busted my kneecap
has been busted I am busted I got fairy
cake this is a huge birthday cake to a
fairy to you it's a grisly reminder that
you kill the fairy on his birthday
foreign
[Laughter]
oh no
oh man that's so sad oh damn what have
we done guys oh man
hey a code anger cool
ah
like a shovel ah oops oh no that's not
right
oh man
that's just uh oops that's uh my bad
guys that's really my bad what you what
are you a mushling okay so you're gonna
conjure up a mushling you're gonna hit
six damage good God I need AOE stuff
okay you're gonna explode that's fine
Molly buttons for four that's fine
three random for that that's not fine
um I'll say my wumpest thing for you
though
uh
uh well let's uh
do this
because you yeah one lump will do that
for you press B to bust that is such an
old joke on my CH that's such an old
reference like I can't even date when
that would be
because that's another wow that's an
evolution of B to blow it and and my God
that is ancient
don't well you did it
hmm
oh thank you
okay so kill this one
the clap of 80 89 I don't know what
you're talking about now there are
references that you guys will make that
I have no idea what it is even like I I
I don't know things that I say even in
videos that I've made just recently I
don't know how you would expect me to
know things that I've said in videos so
long ago that like it makes me seem
dated
do you guys have anything else to say
besides bust
bust any anything but bust anything
anything there's so many more jokes to
make than bust why where's all of my
where's all my thinly veiled threats
that's really what I enjoyed I want you
to like
try to try to strain your brain to be
able to come up with things that are
just like really really nice elegant
thinly veiled threats that's what we all
need right now I need to feel threatened
anytime that I'm streaming needs to be a
like a I should fear for my life kind of
deal you know what I mean
I'm a bastard you better bust right now
[Laughter]
oh baby we both
why about don't I don't know why about
don't
beat it is that the I couldn't make you
bust that's uh something else entirely
uh uh you you that I don't have anything
to say keep it up buster
that's great that's very funny guys very
funny very funny
you guys are so funny
oh more fairies God there's just so many
fairies there's a whole flock of fairies
here all armed with Rusty needles it
seems they're like they're practicing
their fencing skills but they're
fighting style is too chaotic it's hard
to tell Buster busted
that's good that's good
um all of them are needlers so
yeah whatever I'll just ship them down
one at a time
I'm playing bust overloathing yeah I'm
sure the developers who spend so much
time making this game would love for you
to reduce their game down just to a
series of bustings that's all that we
really have
it's like barely checks out as a joke
even at this point
bus to Google Calendar I think you're
just putting things in a random word
generator at this point there's there's
really nothing that you could say that
would actually make any sense off of
that one
Another One Bites the bust I don't like
you I don't like any of this it's
getting warm in this room and I I've got
so much more of this game to go that I'm
enjoying that I am loving and I want to
do it justice and I want to play it
properly and I will but at the same time
I should have healed myself oh that was
not a good idea
I kill you
can I do I have any health ah
perfect
[Laughter]
I did not expect that all right cool
cool uh five
five damage
baloney
fine
bust air bust is a way of life
oh no step buster
oh step brother I'm stuck in the bust a
step Buster you watch yourself step
Buster you must be noodles down
there's only there's only room
for one Buster in this town am I gonna
die was I not paying attention and I'm
now going to die because I think I am
okay whatever
it's about the same
foreign I keep forgetting that actually
playing the game involves combat oh I
can turn up the speed though wait a
minute I can turn up the speed I just
remember that I can actually turn if you
guys would ever actually focus and give
me some actual advice maybe that I'd be
able to play this game properly wow it
was both of their birthdays
that's so sad for them but I can turn up
the game speed right speed combat whamp
there we go perfect
combat styles are disabled when combat
speed is set this High trust us it's
better this way but
where's this God what is this the foot
from a big statue that's how far away
you are away from this and what it is
a foot from
shut up shut up you listen to the Statue
it's sad about the passage of time but
you manage to make it feel better by
reminding it that it's still a really
big really strong foot it gives you some
toe jam
that's gesture of thanks
powerful grit even though it's just an
inert powder you're still pretty sure
it's going to bully you
we have a story in my life so I guess
that's fine
anything else here that I could wow
someone threw away an entire fence I'm
sure oh
what is a teetering stack of crates is
holding up part of the ceiling here kick
it
I what the trash has collapsed into an
unsafe staircase-like Heap that was
extremely lucky
you're right it is
I
I'm shaking and busting right now look I
think we started this stream off on the
wrong foot there's really really truly
no need for you to share this much of
anything
uh oh damn it
but hey I wasn't done
I didn't get what I came for trying to
find a compass
shoot dang wait a minute wait a house
do some of those fairies have guns that
seem strange
all right some of them have guns plow
through them
oh wow they are fast
okay I haven't done anything there's so
many of you
why are there so many of you
you're gonna explode okay you're gonna
shoot
you're gonna poke
you're gonna do whatever you do you're
gonna wump okay so I guess I gotta get
the one that's gonna shoot a bunch of
people
a fairy gunmother
no not the Expo
oh this is gonna go poorly
please at least hit that one once there
we go
okay man I miss having sounds this is
all this is all sad
why is it so sad and slow and
too or fast the opposite is slow what
did I say
okay if you can shoot that one and
actually kill it nope
oh
somehow we're still alive I don't know
how but we're still alive so if I give
you this
and then heal myself
and then hurt you the pine Needler
Wham
okay no God damn it
oh
everybody hold on to your pants this is
where combat gets really dicey
okay that was good that was good
it's no more mushrooms please
you could do whatever you're doing
because I just need to take care of
somebody well no I should oh that's not
gonna kill you anyway might as well kill
one of these
oh no don't do six don't do six okay
I was extremely lucky
I feel like they should just disappear
if I'm
if I'm it's basically done
I know I know I know it was weird and
quiet I know
why your bust so Rusty I don't know what
you're talking about I have no idea what
you're talking about that didn't make
any sense and even if it did I don't
want it to whoa what is that someone is
throwing away a perfectly good giant
novelty pickle big piggy bank
200 feet
oh
and then a shadow Rift
why am I a robot
what why am I a robot
why am I
a robot
why am I a robot
what a thr I don't ex don't describe any
ring as throbbing a throbbing ring of
negative energy around a smaller less
throbbing ring of negative energy
too many things are described as
throbbing and given that this is the
only one that I've seen that's still too
many is that a brain no
that's probably fine
okie dokie then
oh
an inviting tub of piping hot water
piping hot and clean water your brain is
insisting that this is impossible and
the rest of your body is yelling at it
to shut up have a soak
you take off your clothes behind the
privacy of this narration box and slide
into the tub your aches pains and
various worries Drift Away into the
luxurious
you splish around for a while it's very
relaxing
oh wow reluctantly you leave the tub and
dry yourself off with the towel you find
in a nearby pile of trash before putting
your clothes back on that was fantastic
that was don't guys stop
[Laughter]
what's it with you you guys and
throbbing so much why you guys gotta be
throbbing
all right I flushed
why you guys throbbing so much why are
you guys busting so much throbbing so
much worrying about the title so much
you guys worry a bit too much about
everything you guys don't need to worry
about anything I looked away for one
second
that's me with this stream all the time
I look away for one second and oh wow
you guys are talking about
um uh the same thing but worse ringing
this Bell would certainly stir up some
angry fairies
okay
uh
throbbing cookie okay let's try to get
something else here right let's try to
get something else what's another meme
that you guys just can't let go of
because uh I I know that if I dangle the
key chain of uh something else we can
get the we can get it going somewhere in
a slightly different direction okay what
about
we talk about how our day is you just
gotta hear what the [ __ ] is the title
look the title is the least of your
concerns the title doesn't even make any
any impact on the kind of conversations
we're having here the title is literally
not at all a concern at all oh a fairy
skull wand
tiny wand is tip with a fairy skull
which is like a human skull except it's
only about an inch in diameter
wow wand core make any weapon into a
wand which will use your mysticality to
determine stem oh what a nice
okay so what did that do
the wall of trash is riddled with fairy
tunnels oh it's a farming spot okay so
this is just where I could Farm up some
uh things so this is a good opportunity
because we can chat
we can just chat we can have a good old
time
how are you what's my favorite game
Aesthetics
what is that which game do I find the
sexiest is that what you just asked
what
what game do I find attractive is that
what you just asked me
watch learn to speak that's not an
option anymore we're not even remotely
in that same area we're nowhere near
where that is so ow I just got shot in
the head
you're making a presentation yeah what
game is the sexiest I don't know
why would you ask me that I'm not the
guy that keeps track of that kind of
stuff I don't know what game is the
sexiest what game is the sexiest
and I mean there'd be obvious answers uh
it's weird that such vile creatures can
still have such a nice dandruff a
horrible
like you know with the hoony pops and
whatnot but I'm talking about something
else you've cleared out the fairies at
least for now there will probably be
more fairies if you come back tomorrow
if you want that for some inexplicable
reasons how fast do fairies breed
I hate that I even asked the wait a
minute
holy dang somebody threw away a
perfectly good cow skull these are rare
as heck considering that there haven't
been any cows in this country for more
than 30 years
I got a mountain cow skull cool this
would look great in your room
it's always hard to tell whether one of
these is part of a normal cow somebody
killed for sport or the entirety of
horrible floating cow skulls somebody
killed in self-defense
yeah you right ah geiger counter is
really going nuts this must be the spot
just beneath the surface your shovel
strikes to top of a creek the geiger
counter continues this irritating
clickery see you guys totally forgot
that we were here for a mission
you're watching The Last of Us did that
show come out I have been watching most
TV anyway but I haven't had a chance for
that
yeah
bust the cow skull I'm not gonna do that
orc massage I don't know what you talk
about orc massage is a very family
friendly extremely family friendly uh
family the friendliest of families work
massages I don't know if you guys saw my
video uh but it's pretty clear
that [ __ ] is so friendly hey Buck over
here what
what he he this is the berries I ain't
got in this many fights in ages what you
don't do a lot of fighting for the mob
oh they're all wet always giving me an
earful shooting up the places bad for
business blah blah blah I'm glad you're
enjoying yourself okay cool
all right uh we got what we need we need
to go get the thing from the guy in the
lighthouse and I know I haven't visited
all these different things
I'm weak as [ __ ]
but eventually I will be able to do that
bust the family friendly I don't think
you know what you're talking about I
don't think you are in any way qualified
to say such things to me so also how
dare you and uh how dare you give me
your compass see that's what it is
give me your compass
let's see hmm could use a Polish but it
seems to be in good condition all right
I'll swap you let me get that old geiger
counter back from you too I got a cursed
compass
this Compass always points towards the
evil version of North this should not be
followed
well I don't know about you guys but I
kind of want to follow it
can I
follow it
how can I uh
follow it
is there a way to follow this thing
can I follow the compass
how do I follow compass
I'll wander a bit
you're walking around through the woods
around Chris ah there's a huge spider it
jumps down out of nowhere and aims its
butt right at your face and shoots
blob of web at you
time slows down around you is the
horrible sticky wad sails through the
air directly at the part of your head
where you keep all your most important
sensory organs sorry I guess that was a
weird way to phrase it I couldn't think
of a good synonym for faith
I can dodge it all the way or fail oh
man guys
yeah sorry ah there's a huge throbbing
spider it jumps down out of nowhere and
aims its throbbing butt right at your
throbbing face and Sh and busts a huge
glob of throbbing web I'm gonna Dodge
you duck and roll out of the incoming
goop and just keep rolling until you're
completely out of this part of the woods
God damn I love this game oh this game
so much look this that was horrible look
it was horrible for you I was standing I
was about to get wadded I was about to
get wadded in the face you think I
wasn't happy about that oh [ __ ]
oh you see your past self coming up the
road towards you and remember that 300
meat you owe you maybe you ought to pay
that back so the Paradox doesn't destroy
causality or something
bad
how bad could it possibly be how bad
could it possibly be that's my money
ask my money
ask my money why would I give that to
anybody else why would I give that my
money that's my meat
I'm a bust reality I'm avoiding no don't
talk to me I don't even want to see you
the curse compass needle Twitches to
life if you can call it living and
thrust its pointy head urgently so
I don't like those descriptions it leads
you to the trunk of an ancient tree
though the tree May once have stood
proudly in the days before cities and
Men it is now infirm wisened and
dribbling sweet-smelling sap from a
thousand little holes
there's not much left in the old guy
drain the tree for all this happens
I'm gonna suck that tree dry I'm gonna
slurp all of its sweet smelling sap out
of its thousands of holes all of its
tiny little holes are gonna get drained
dry where's my hose I'm gonna hook it up
to this thing and I'm gonna slurp it dry
I'm gonna slurp it drown get ready tree
you're about to bust your last sap
I got a shadow milkshake farewell old
tree to everyone there's a season that
is uh Etc
wait
like Chris Scott was twitch is alive it
leads you to an ancient tree there's not
much out of there all right see I'm you
ready for round two I bet you thought
you were done it's never done when I'm
in town get that trunk throbbing again
it's sucking time slurp
this way you get if you if you get If
instead of a soda jerk your local cafe
employed a soda nihilist
hilarious
all right three threes times a charm you
better throw up in threes cause the rule
of Threes is the rule of trees and you
better just
give me your sap
you ever just suck a tree God damn it
all right three fourth times for me you
wish you could be I ain't no never see
again cause I'm I'm gonna have sap
gushing out my ears when I'm done with
you you better watch yourself
one more time all right oh a squirrel
brings a large uncracked nut for to you
for assistance this takes a lot of
humility for a squirrel all right
squirrel you better back the [ __ ] up I'm
about to get that nut holy sh I'm too
weak for this shake your head and say
not today sorry squirrel look I just
sucked four trees in a row I'm a little
weak right now I'm weak in the knees
look I I I I I could but I can't crack
it with a bum knee like this did you
guys know I crashed my bike I said that
already but new people might be here or
people that watch this in the future and
for some reason Jump Ahead to right now
or the horrifying horrifying people that
watch this [ __ ] in two times speed who
does that why would you do that what's
wrong with you anyway bye squirrel sorry
squirrel I'm not strong enough but what
I could do is I could
foreign
level up a bit how about these and hot
armor that's good
I'll do that
about wisdom of yarulberg that's pretty
good
about how about this one because I get
plus five XP from fights that would like
uh increase my XP a lot or this one
no I might get more my yeah yeah but I
mean oh man it's too late now I I can't
do anything about that
anyway I'm out of here
I'm wandering
a squirrel Chatters angrily at you from
a nearby hollow tree presumably trying
to scare you from its stash a real
tactical mistakes on its part since now
you know where its stashes it scampers
away as you appear into its hole you
find not just the expected nuts but
several wallets has the squirrel been
mugging hikers maybe you should get out
of here before it comes back with a
knife
fair enough fair enough you see my pet
nah I don't want to pay back my past
self look you found a decaying
nightstand discarded in a ditch which is
kind of a weird place to find a
nightstand maybe someone got so mad
about stubbing their toes all the time
they angrily drove it out of the woods
and threw it out of the car
I got junk mail
an old match and comfy hat lining
well good for me I'm going to the
Crystal Store I'm I feel like I need to
get my crystals in order my resonance is
all out of whack as you're heading down
one of the idyllic paths around the lake
you encounter a giant fallen tree
blocking your way forward I'm weak as
[ __ ] I can't do it
crystals
it's a weird pocket and nothingness
all right I've never seen a hole that I
didn't want to stick myself elbow deep
in so I'm going in that that seems like
a really bad idea are you sure yeah I
can't stress enough that you shouldn't
do this it might give you some kind of
Shadow disease or it might just bite
your hand clean off or anything I'm
shoving look I've never seen a hole that
I did not want to shove myself in elbow
deep how clear can I be I'm clear as
Crystal at the Crystal Store get me in
that hole
you stick your hand into the hole grab
the first thing your fingers brush
against and yank it back out I got a
shadow hot dog
it's also shaped hole in reality it has
been placed into a regular hot dog bun
for your convenience
the shadowy pocket vanishes with an
otherworldly pop
all right good I
look there's nothing untoward about this
stream there's nothing untoward about my
channel everything here is as it should
be and I will not take any criticism
because I never take any [ __ ] from
nobody don't make me do what I did that
whole view
don't make me do that
or that tree you better watch yourself
hey yeah yeah
I stand by my words
I shouldn't but I am standing by my
words
anyway hello the proprietress of this
empty store has nothing to proprietary
what do you sell here what do you think
crystals
crystals you sure think so wouldn't you
huh you sure think a crystal store next
to a crystal mine would tell crystals
what in here
please you're using too many italics I
can't focus
let me tell you a little story about a
young woman whose name is me please
don't
my parents wanted me to go straight into
college so that's what I did but college
girls they're only thinking about one
thing getting a degree so they can work
in a mine I'm not like regular girls guy
I want to sell things that come out of
my mind sure gases and such
so I dropped out and moved across 13
states to the best crystal mine in the
country but when I arrived the mine was
about a business and now so am I before
I even got started
uh so what are you still doing here
I missed why he wanted to sell crystals
want me to check out that mine
yeah break me off a couple crystals you
were thinking
uh
not asking you to clear out the whole
mind man but with just a few crystals I
can afford to send my whole sorority
down there your sorority I'll see what I
can do all right
take care I'm gonna go into mine
I make like a crystal and clear out
shut up
the cursed compass
all right tree [ __ ] it's time for round
six I hope
I can't think of any other word to rhyme
but dicks
you ain't whittling Dixie
give me your sap
yeah I got a shadow milkshake I wonder
what would happen I fed the shadow
milkshake to that dude gumbuckle mine
Foreman's office good thing I have a
crowbar good thing I never sell anything
and never throw it away why would I do
that oh another hole
another hole all right you
okay don't read what this says here
don't read even though I'm really
emphasizing it what does that look like
to you
you stick your hand in the hole grab the
first thing your fingers brush against
and yank it back out
I got a shadow clarinet
it might be an oboe it's hard to tell
with all the endless void pouring into
our world through its empty silhouette
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
anyway whatever all right who is this a
little radio playing some big band music
cabinet securely locked coat rack is
bare nothing on this desk except a very
old pink slip the reason for termination
is listed as sharking of elevator
maintenance duties
filing cabinet flip file flip-flops
makes my steps more organized
okay
yeah okay all right okay
okay
all right so I gotta go back in time
we it's a 1906 calendar a desk with
nothing on or in or under or behind it a
huge disappointment really an empty bird
cage they must have run out of canaries
oh fortunately this version of the cabin
is empty God
damn it
whatever uh there's a jacket I got a key
oh cabinet key
I bet it's not going to be empty this
time
click open oh empty except for one can
of elevator Grease
grease it up baby it's too far gone for
Greece to help at this point you really
hope somebody got fired for you okay
what about in the past
can I go outside in the past I can
I can indeed Greece a squirt here a
dollop there and kapow this thing will
run like a charm for at least 22 years
oh
nice
nice greasy and throbbing I swear to God
I look over
being like I wonder what my lovely Chad
is up to I wonder what those wonderful
people over there are up to and I just
see greasy and throbbing what am I
supposed to assume that goes on in your
mind when all I do is look over and see
that what is wrong with you I I don't
see all the oh boy
oh man this is so great oh you're doing
so good I better keep playing or I'll
murder you in your sleep it's just
greasy and throbbing that's what I see
what's up with that
no
what is wrong with my arm how many times
I gotta talk about this I crashed my
bike
I smashed it I swashed it that's my arm
that's my knee this is my eyeball
can you see
can you see that can you see I don't
know if you can see that
how about blood vessels all exploding in
my eye so you know it is what it is so
there's what happens this would happen
definitely
why would I lie
why would I lie
I wouldn't lie
Never Lie
anyway how's my toe oh my toes fine I
smashed my thumb yesterday too I smashed
my thumb so bad it it bent back around
like a third of the way in it was
bleeding everywhere was horrible I've
really been Wang doodling myself
the support being this lousy with
termites I'll suck those termites right
out of that beam
see what I say table is bare except for
a note reading iou1 helmet this cabin is
labeled Dynamite storage and it is
extremely locked all right what what
a very large oddly spherical rock it has
a hole drilled in it
I've never met a hole that I didn't want
to shove myself elbow deep inside I'm
guessing this is the world's first
flashlight when caveman first roused
themselves out of the stupidness of the
Stone Age they looked for a rock that
they could pork and they made this
horrible monster
dude what the hell I'm matching your
energy
why am I the weird one when it's you
that set the standard for what this the
attitude of this stream would be I
didn't have anything to do with this
I didn't have anything to do with this
this was all your fault this was all
your fault what a horrible day though
to speak English yes it is I'm shining
my flashlight in flashlight reveals
sparkly colored crystals inside it's a
geode
oh
well that's nice if I could blow it up
then mayhaps I'll have a a good thing to
do hmm
so
maybe in the future those locks are so
rusted that they're all blown up and
maybe the grease lasted into the future
so that it's maintained wow
this elevator has been remarkably well
maintained
Buster is I don't think that's look you
can't match my unfathomable RIS but look
I learned Riz from Ethan and and
I'd
It's Just Swag it's the same thing
it's the same thing and and I I'm pretty
sure we all agreed that swag was a
horrifying thing to say and or
experience so I don't the risk is too
much
I don't think you can bust a rib
throbbing riffs
[Laughter]
look don't ask you don't you you don't
want to know the rizz is too loud yes it
is
oh massive cave-in
there's a big crack in the wall here
well nothing I can do about that
uh so what do I do I don't know let me
go back to Crystal Store and see what
oddly rectangular Brown Rock catches
your attention turns out to be
completely rusted and partially sunk old
pre-war soda cooler although someone
fitted a meat operated lock onto the
door do the roast you can't tell check
the meat return
no way the only thing you'd likely get
out of that old rustole would be
deadness I'll buy a soda
nice coal is so old and Rusty you can't
even tell whether it's red or blue maybe
some kind of horrible Brown Cola that
you never heard of before
all right fair enough uh the mine's all
well I missed why you wanted to sell
your name's Crystal okay whatever
look it's it's fine don't worry about it
I don't know so there's got to be
something else that I've I've missed in
this mine so I'm gonna go
blue Cola
paisoda I should buy more soda because
those things are dabligibles
they're damaged kind of things no stop
there's got to be a way to open up the
law
there's got to be a way there has to be
a way everyone I I know you're you're
busy doing all the busting and all the
rizzing and all the throbbing that
you're doing but I need you to focus and
look at me look at me look at me look at
me look at me look at me for a moment
just look at me look at me look at me
look at me look at me hey
we need to use our brains on this one we
need to work together on this one we
need to figure out a solution so that we
can actually make this happen okay
okay
it's the termites
of course
of course
at hermites
hermites I need to remove the termites
how do okay that's enough I don't want
any more turn your brain off turn your
brain off turn off your braining before
it's too late no you're res your wrist
is going out of control all right so
there's got to be a way yeah
so there's got to be something that I
can do to get rid of termites
okay
uh-huh
brain is too loud
yeah you're right you're right you're
right okay all right we're all back to
normal you guys can resume your normal
busting and throbbing activities
what fight him what am I doing fight him
who am I fighting I don't care I want
him to what's an orb that's an orb all
right
oh they're vampires
I didn't even notice that
get off of me
oh
all right whatever man these guys are
really really easy
these guys are real easy throbbing
orbias it was a throbbing orb
congratulations
I got a what's a blue dead it's a piping
out strudel filled with blood instead of
I don't know raspberries or whatever
strudels normally have in them nice
I think that one I think I'm using I'm
taking his credit for myself I'm pretty
sure but I discovered that there was
something at the hardware store that I
could use
uh termite
perfect can I turn my poison I wish
regulatory agency made me stop selling
it a few years back because he was quote
unquote killing everybody who used it
huh so more of an everything poison then
yeah Wicked gerd for termite though
uh what do you have for sale
um cooking with power tools love that
steel toed boots uh love that used
plunger love that self-adhesive rivets
love that battery love that Oz goodbye
everything no no give it back give it
back
God damn it wasted my meat now I can't
even pay back my past self
what am I gonna do with okay so if that
wasn't where I get poisoned then in the
past
of course
hello sir
what do you have for sale do you have
any
fuse
plunger didn't I buy these already
I feel like I did but I'm buying them
again
peculiar time's a real funny thing you
got any poison
guy Poison
aha termite poison
[Laughter]
I gotta go get some meat I don't have
any
and I know I could sell some things but
I'm not gonna do that because that's for
quitters and if there's one thing that
I'm not it's a quitter I don't I look
guys this is actually a big brain move
because I needed to wander some more you
don't ask me why
freaking pay that car back right now I
am really low on money okay here we go
fight them
perfect
die die you wackadoo
and then die you other thing
and then die also with this
don't laugh at me
easy
I I only have rizz for Amy and Lady D I
don't think you can have rizz for post a
risk
[Laughter]
what's wrong with me I can't even buy
meat
[Music]
plow I'm plowing
I'm fighting it
damn you damn you for making those webs
look at this one look at this one right
here that Twitchy ass spider shut up
except my Riz
damn God damn I could sell all these
I won't
because I can't sell anything ever you
never know when you're gonna need
extract the oil
well that's not
that's not money that's not okay Amber
well this is incredible I don't have
anything
it's not a throbbing spider that's not
what it is you shut up I can't pay me
back I don't have anything
look I don't look don't ask me where the
G-Spot is uh
who knows look this isn't the type of
place for that this isn't anything this
is not sex ed this is not that's not the
kind of questions you ask me all right
oh God now there
man this is why I I can't say anything
at all to you guys because you're just
the worst kind of parrots you're the
worst little seagulls from uh Finding
Nemo
God where's any meat giving me meat
please scare them silly a gaggle of Boy
Scouts around a campfire plead with you
for a scary story for their scoutmaster
as they say have proven frightfully
unfrightening scare them silly oh yes
yeah
fairy layer maybe there's something here
for me for me hey look another hole
Shadow elixir
die fairies die
die
die more
take your time
die further
okay well I win and I don't have any
money
this is a fairy nest
I have a hand injury
I need meat give me meat
give me Mead where's my meat don't shoot
me wrong with you
fine whatever
just like in real life
yeah guys look times are tough I ain't
got no meat I got no meat guys I don't
know what's going on
look I'm really really hurting for it
[Music]
oh good great now this flight's gonna
last longer
out of the wrist
guys I feel like this is somehow my
fault because I started this whole thing
off with the title that it is the title
that it is is just was just asking for
trouble
wow this thing is horrible must be meant
to scare humans away take it back to my
room
wait seriously you just want to take
this obviously evil extremely ugly
statue back to your room where you sleep
yeah you're not going to be able to drag
it out of here with the fairies still
running loose in the area a good point
150.
50 I got a fairy knife sweet
take this
take this
take this
tank
take this
God damn why they got a gun
how they got a gun that's a real
question
damn that's nice
what's a seagull rizzler God you're just
mishmashing the most random assortment
of words that I say there's no logic to
anything that you're talking about there
can't be if there is logic I don't want
to know what that logic is because it
terrifies me the logic that you're
trying to suggest that you actually have
is off I'm vibrating with what
I'm gonna reach inside
who rocks hey
no not Molly oh Captain e now attack Now
deals of extra five damage oh sweet
Josue that's weird
hey
screw you
okay man we got a lot of oh you're gonna
explode well that's not so bad
okay uh okay uh okay you die
foreign
[Music]
smooth brain move I don't know what did
I just do I don't even remember what I
did it must have been incredibly amazing
was it incredible and amazing I have a
funny feeling that it was incredible and
amazing
it was incredible and amazing wasn't it
my stork has unlimited Riz I don't know
what that means what is what does that
even mean have I tried going to the bank
and getting a meat loan is that possible
are you just joking with me
are you raising me right now I don't
know if that's a proper usage of the
word Riz but it feels right
don't RIS me bro
don't don't RIS me bro
don't you dare it's like leveling up
your charisma right that's why it's
based off of so you got I've maxed out
my Charisma so my Riz is unfathomable
crew
literally just like you guys remind me
of my niece
because she just only speaks in memes
and
slang and Tick Tock quotes so all it is
like just the entire conversation that I
have and she's 13 and it's just like oh
man you got W Riz oh blah blah that's
the only thing I could remember
I think
I have no idea I have no idea what
anything's going on here look I'm
I'm horrifically old I'ma take this now
anyway
you drag the horrible sculpture to the
bus stop a bus arrives but refuses to
pick you up because of the horrible
sculpture you spend the next several
hours dragging it back to your room
oh I really did
you hang the cow skull over your desk if
anybody asks I'll tell them you killed
the cow yourself thanks how knee hurts
my knee hurts guys I need pity points I
I need busy points I'm pissy on my I've
got unfathomable pissy guys my my knee
hurts you see that that's blood that's
blood from my wounds that's blood it's
blood from my wounds
oh just looking at the thing makes you
mad pretend to fight it take this you
duck and weave bob and SWAT are you
Shadow Boxing or the Shadows boxing you
you're charged up with violent fairy
magic
I am
I am indeed apparently what if I take a
nap can I take a nap can I sleep nope
can't sleep
how do I get over to uh b b for bus stop
I'm back at the lake now
I I can jump
since when can I jump
it's always been a thing weird all right
I have money now I'm gonna go get the
freaking poison which I meant to do a
long time ago that's the problem with
this game you just get sidetracked and
then you'll never get anywhere because
there's just so much to do which is
great I love the game for that and I
love that it is that that way that it is
but also at the same time I've got [ __ ]
to do not really I don't know [ __ ]
I've just been playing a lot of Dragon
dragonflight World of Warcraft
dragonflight and I've been making so
much soup
like everyone seems to not okay this is
gonna go over everyone's head if you
don't play World of Warcraft right but I
got back into it and I was like man this
is really cool and everyone's like oh
it's so hard to level up the iscar
Renown I'm level 30 renowned with them
just because I do the soup all the time
I love the soup event anybody that says
the soup event is boring is stupid and
shut up it's amazing if you if you if
you go to do the soup event and you just
sit there and do nothing I hate you with
every fiber of my being you are actively
making the entire event worse because
you'll get assigned some [ __ ] to go uh
fish up like some ice back sculpin and
you don't do it and that slows
everything down and then it goes
everywhere it's confusing use your brain
increase your risk and get your brain
out of your brain
it's good it's great I love it I'll take
it anyway
you buy the pesticide and place it very
carefully in your sack
thermoblast let's turn my spray mind you
don't get any of that on your skin and
don't bring you to the fumes and don't
pour it down and it drains or rivers or
otherwise let it get into the
groundwater and if the jar starts to
melt get it into a fresh yard straight
away all rightyro alrighty or can I
drink it
damn
I don't know why that was my first
instinct there anyway but dragonflight's
cool I got a question for y'all
do you think
do you think that if you had a raid full
of just hunters and I mean just Hunters
all Beast Master spec so each one has
two pets so you have 40 hunters and 80
pets
do you think anything could stop you I
don't think so no I don't think you
heard the rest of my question
could anything stop you that's the
question could anything stop you no I
don't think I don't think you could
skeleton is immobile bound to its Chair
by Vines and drizzles of sap in its hand
are a knife and fork dinner meal I'm
taking this dinner I got Shadows
it would be funny if it weren't so
terrifying maybe that's just the
appetizer but you can't be waiting
around much longer who knows what the
service is like here say bye bye to the
skeleton
lag could stop you
do you guys want to uh no I'm not gonna
do this because I've done this before
and it's been horrible to everybody and
I I feel I still feel bad about it I you
know the mark of peeps Guild uh I I
stranded a lot of people there when I
just stopped playing but it's not my
fault because battle for Azeroth was a
terrible expansion
and it really was awful but Dragon
flight's actually good and I like it
but I'm still not gonna make another
server again I'm not gonna do it I'm not
gonna do it
anyway but I did do it to those termites
though so that's pretty cool
yep
this is the second live I haven't been
on what's the first live this of this
I've only done this what are you talking
about
is there another Markiplier
right there there's not another
Markiplier out there that wouldn't be
it's impossible
support being maybe old but at least
it's not full of termites you're goddamn
right
it's one of those fancy mining helmets I
love that
I love that give me that
the helmet is heavy but it has a light I
love that
I really love that
I love that an extremely enthusiastic
rat has chewed a hole in the solidly
locked cabinet okay I've got a 22 year
old stick of diamonds
great that's gonna help can I put it in
here
wait a minute what if what if this is a
test to willpower and I actually need to
save off on this
and I put it no I thought it might be
going the crack I thought I might stick
this stick in a crack but I didn't I'll
stick it in this hole instead all right
fire in the hole literally oh
you've seen some disappointing
explosions in your life but that one
really failed to even make a dent in the
cake this rock must be made of tougher
stuff than a relatively fresh stick of
dynamite can handle hmm
well that's disappointing
[Music]
what about two sticks of dynamite
oh am I using on my matches oh [ __ ]
I'm using up my matches aren't I well I
didn't do it but if I take this stick of
a dynamite and then I put it in
this big crack in the wall
I know I know take a picture with that
you think I don't know that you think
you think ow
[Music]
I hurt my finger
you can't see it
you can't see it
yeah
[Music]
I boo booed
you see it you see you see the boo boo
you see the Boo-boo
you guys know what to do one like equals
a boo-boo kiss
guys one like mean double kiss
one like one bubble kiss please I won't
heal properly if I don't get enough
Bubble kisses
I need a boo-boo kiss
I need ten thousand bubble kisses or
else it's never gonna angle properly you
know this to be true
[Laughter]
all right he's better oh thank you thank
you for the Booboo kisses my uh my wrist
is returning to me my wrist is stored in
my finger my God my wrist is
unfathomable
oh my God what incredible Riz what about
this what if I used to download in the
past well God damn it
okay
so let's think about this I can get a
piece of dynamite
from the future and obviously I don't
take it to the past and do anything with
it there that's not what I do about with
it
but what I need to do is something with
this dynamite
I can't get past Dynamite because I
can't even get into the tank
how do I I can't get past Dynamite
because wait a minute
wait a minute wait wait I use the
dynamite to get the dynamite because I
used the dynamite on the locks to get
into the dynamite to get fresh Dynamite
when I get that Dynamite because this is
22 year old Dynamite and then when I use
it on that I'll be able to get the good
Dynamite take it back to the whole of it
in the hole
shove it so good in that hole
no
I'm dumb what do I do guys please
let me do
what do I do guys what do I do I need to
make the dynamite older I don't think
that's what I need to do
the support beams
no no no no no no no no no no
what do I do
rizz on the dynamite I don't think that
is it put in hole in past then go
oh no no no no no no
no that can't be right that's silly
table next Dynamite needs the helmet I'm
wearing
oh no it's impossible
no this is ridiculous I'm bald bald bald
okay but no this is
what if I get multiple dynamites and
combine it 40 year old Dynamite greater
than 20 year old Dynamite you need to
put it in the hole in the past and blow
it up in the future
age it like fine wine no God
all right okay I'm gonna take your word
on this because that doesn't make any
goddamn sense however I'm not saying
that it's not gonna work I'm just
pointing out that that don't make any
goddamn sense because if that was just
that it seems ridiculous and I'm running
out of matches but I'm gonna get I'm
gonna get that I'm gonna get it I'm
gonna get it and you're gonna get it if
this doesn't work because if this don't
work I'm gonna give it to you and you're
gonna get it and there's gonna be no
take back season on this you're just
gonna take it
so you better make sure that you're
right because if you're wrong
I won't finish that all right here we go
watch this
sick dynamite in then I go out then I go
up
[Laughter]
huh
what's up what's wrong you guys seem
weird no it's nothing to do with the
crack in the wall this has got to be it
it makes sense if you think about it
really stupidly
foreign
knows that
dynamite gets better
over time like fine fine wine
an extremely old stick of dynamite in
this hole it's practically squirting
[Laughter]
it sure is lighter up
oh
look at it oh you've blown the geode
wide open oh you've completely blown it
out exposing a huge
throbbing variety of crystals you should
let Crystal know
all right
shoot dang awesome ask him Crystal
Hell God damn God damn
first throbbing now squirting uh por que
nolos dos right
porque no Los Dos yeah
all right anyway uh break off anything
expensive yes in fact you did well
that's just great hang on she leaves and
come back an hour later with two big arm
loads of crystals just give me a couple
hours and I'll give you a fully
functional Crystal shop okay what should
I do in the meantime go got some old
magazines oh you're there all right oh
wow oh oh you know this Magazine's
fascinating say did you hear about the
sketchy land grabs up in Oregon I
remember my grandparents talking about
it boy that Mitchell what a sneaky snake
uh anyway got you a little something to
say thanks uh when I was going through
the crystals I found a small one that I
really can't sell for much and I just
thought of you
you remember when the very idea of this
Crystal was no more than a twinkle in
Crystal's eye uh thanks what else you
got in stock whoa
I wish I had more money
heal your entire party once per oh
whoa
whoa oh I need those
what did I need I needed uh I need
stench armor that's for sure and I think
I needed sleaze armor I think those are
the things I needed right
holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
sex crystals I I don't know what that is
whoa I'm avoiding me
avoiding me for
ever I don't have any money I do not
have money I don't know how this
happened but I don't have any money
I don't have any money at all stench
armor go no not you this one
yes I got
you're as lazy the worst pair of pants
you could have ever imagined yay oh but
it's 20 to meat drops which is what I
need that is definitely what I need I
know the Merson
there was something else here slee's
armor was
I'm so right so goddamn right
I got a nasty spoon
grab a nasty old spoon from the pile and
use it to dig through the gloop you
don't find anything so you just keep the
spoon I don't know why you would want to
keep that spoon
from the looks of it the spoon has been
used to eat a lot of unspeakable
chowders
that's a good point I like that better
than my garlic press so I'm gonna use
that oh
but I have the fairy skull wand as well
fine all right so I have that
um
well I like the haversack that's awesome
and I got the trash soaked pants
man I am gross
I'm really living up to Muffler
bumperdink here with all the stink I got
the thumperding stink going on here all
right I need to go distillery in the pet
store
Never Gonna Let Me Down bust the pants I
don't know hey is you a vampire
be gone from these plays you'll have no
business here not really no I'm just
curious how'd you make your eyes do that
also I like you're not quite Romanian
accent uh thank you what's with those
huge vampire fangs though wait a minute
are you a vampire
I feel like if I said no you'd actually
believe me well not anymore
okay then yes I am a vampire
okay gosh leave these places once or the
consequences will be most dire
oh come on don't be like that what's
eating you if you do not leave any
questions we'll leave with this evening
oh and the answer will be me this is
terrible
anyway oh wait bewitch
I'll show you
hey you want to be confused
take this oh you cannot write me oh I
know
for your power issues from the darkness
of the night and I the night oh jeez I
completely lost track of time she looks
up at the midday sun and her hair bursts
into flames
huh
all right then
this door is locked with the government
issue combination lock must be a
Prohibition thing
yep your civilian brain makes short work
of the lock
I could squirm through them
I could but should I I don't have a
choice anymore you know I'm still gonna
scream I'm gonna scream through it I
skirmed
I squirmed right through that almost
everything on the Shelf is busted up
trash but there's one unsmashed crate of
Brews got a crate of rum
well that's nice
I could take that to bumperdinck's drink
make some potions
oh
no
I know that there's probably some things
that I could do with just making a with
the made products but I don't know what
to do so I'm not gonna do nothing
there's a label on this vat that reads
Grandpa Joe's extra fancy garlic
schnapps wow maybe it wasn't prohibition
that put this place out of business let
me see if I can get enough stench armor
I don't think I can can I I could do
sleeves but I can't do stench
okay sorry there's a bunch of vampires
hanging out near and it probably
shouldn't be surprised that they've
noticed you that's him that's him right
there okay
hello
I'm going to kill you
I'm going to kill you I'm going to kill
you now
I'm going to kill you
oh wait
you're right
you're so right I'm almost dead oh my
God wait a minute what happened
don't kill me
I'm still alive somehow I don't know how
but you're right the gas mask why didn't
any of you suggest the gasque mat the
gas mask the gas mask
the gas
mask okay you'll die from that
I'm gonna use the can
well
[Music]
oh oh I was relying on that
all right
well you're gonna get this
and then you're going to get this
that's right I know the gas mask
more like the Rhythm
right everybody
because we use our Riz to hide our true
bait inside of ourselves
all right whatever shut up
shut up
here we go
stankiness here I come you crank open
the valve and dump about 12 gallons of
pure distilled garlic juice onto the
floor wow even with stench protection
it's a nasal experience you won't soon
forget the vampire is completely FL
ah
I could have waited anyway some turned
into Miss and shoot out the cracks in
the ceiling and some just run out the
front door after that you hear several
screams as they realize it's still
daytime outside all righty
those battle is intentionally empty
unfriendly bat do not use yeah but still
drum bang on it wow sad
[Music]
uh create a booze okay create a gin I've
got rum engine that's nice
oh
a porcus torque
a a a a
porkus torque when you apply poison
apply three extra I wish I could that'd
be nice vampire boots
these were invented when a cobbler
accidentally mispronounced vampire bats
that's hilarious okay
cosmetic wine does that even mean but I
got vampire boots
make me float oh
I like it let me take the gas mask off
because I don't need that anymore let me
put my Fedora back on
oh you scared
all right I'm going to the pet store
I don't know why I'm going to every
single place here but I just feel like I
need to how do I not have enough
mysticality for that
how do I not have enough mystery uh
probably because I don't have any of my
mysticality items on
yep I'm dumb
no I still wouldn't have been able to do
it
[Music]
[Music]
yeah whatever
hey what the hell the bees box full of
bees a bee box you think it's called
yeah sure
meet your next best friend today oh
scrawny looking cat is sleeping
oh my goodness everybody huh
[Music]
good fronds are hard to find oh man
hi
hello there welcome to Greta's
compassion and pet store I'm Greta hi
Greta I'm Mark can I ask you a question
of course where are all the pets oh
they're out back in cages now in the
woods what stops them from leaving
compassion
okay what pets do you have for sale oh
got this snake available for adoption
I've also got one giant mosquito left
[Laughter]
a giant mosquito hey don't knock it a
mosquito is great to have on your side
in a fight not only can they suck the
blood out of stuff they can also
[Music]
[Laughter]
you can also pump that blood into you to
heal you mathematically speaking that's
twice the powder
power
that's so horrible
it's the most horrible thing I've ever
heard
I have to go get more meat to be able to
get that I'll be right back
I got a coat I gotta get some meat guys
wait I gotta make sure I have all my
plus okay I got my plus to meet drops
oh God I can't pay myself back guys I
really can't
all right who's this ah nuts I stepped
in weird mushrooms okay whatever
discover a ring identify the pattern
okay oh man I just gotta go to the
hardware store and sell some crap
okay banish them sure boom
boom
I don't think throbbing and pumping will
get me the meat I don't even know where
you got pumping from like I feel like
I've been here for most of this time and
I don't remember
I don't remember when pumping was
involved okay I'm gonna sell some of
that I'm not gonna sell anything that I
don't have a double of right
I'm gonna sell things I have extras
and no more fairy cakes I could do that
I killed fairies I don't need that many
very dust very knife
I've got two Ferris skull ones I can get
rid of one of those
fragrance Bears glob of spider webs I
almost got that right to the face match
I need those piece of scrap metal on the
other I need that sharpening stone I
know I bought that so I don't wanna okay
who wouldn't handle one of those okay
that's enough I'm gonna get myself a
giant mosquito because this this this
raven
this raven never did nothing for nobody
Hey look it's meat
never did not the mosquito is throbbing
I don't think it is
I I think you're wrong about that I
don't I don't think it's throbbing I
don't think it's throbbing at all give
me the skeeter give it to me now I just
need to give it a name all right guys
I need a name
I need a name for this mosquito and guys
I swear to God if you don't get this
good
is gonna be sucky
[Music]
Court
these are
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh we can't name them throb that's for
damn sure that would be awful
foreign
I like squirt because that that actually
could be a no I mean when I wrote it out
it sounds much horrible because isn't
that a nickname hey squirt and not a
nickname
can't be rizz it can't be slurred
Robert
[Laughter]
I could go Robert
you're crying you call these things
Robert
[Laughter]
wait I'm sorry 2b1 Robert
yeah one b one b is correct I don't know
why I was doing two B's just on me
Robert
all right it's Robert we got Robert the
mosquito that's fantastic thanks Greta I
think
oh tell me about the snake you can't go
wrong world's most dangerous rope
nah totally fill your enemies up with
boys
all right I'm good for now
all right let's get Robert in here oh
man I forgot I had a turtle who cares
Robert give me give me Robert
all right thriver let's let's go we
gotta go back man we've been so long in
this place we totally forgot about the
main reason we were doing any of this
which is the freaking compass
I got that Compass remember you sent me
out there forever ago oh good not too
much of an ordeal I hope could have been
worse I guess there were some horrible
fairies what no don't tell me just
uncursed that thing and get some rest
okay I think the next artifact is a book
I'll have the location by morning
okie dokie then
I sit in the chair which is surprisingly
comfortable and pull the weird metal
Dome thing over your head what would you
like to uncures Shadow tainted compass
you sit with the compass in both hands
as the machine wurs and whines and
shakes around you the machine you feel
is frustrated some internal mechanism is
swinging wildly frantically then crack
it figures out whatever it needs to and
there's no more curse not in the compass
not anymore still points to Old North
though so it's practically useless
Compass curse is now transfixed in the
uncursing machine do you dare project
Consciousness inside I will dare
it's dare or nothing
then it's there
oh
you all right bud
gosh that looks sore
this is madness that foolhardy coach is
gonna get us all killed we should listen
to what the ghost shots say what do you
think we ought to do let's get out of
here go home don't you think things were
fine just the way they were why are we
doing this you mean playing baseball he
looks you dead in the eye and manages a
nervy chuckle yeah that's right kid
all right we'll see you
I'm just I'm disgusted that it's come to
this we all know you're the weak link on
the team some would say the team of
cotton shouldn't even be allowed on the
field but you tell me did all my years
of including you in team lunches and
burpees make you into a baseball player
yes coach I'm ready to hit the balls
that's what I wanted to hear your
Destinies out there on the diamond sun
go and hit it into the parking lot
say coach why do you wear that funny uh
cheat codes you think Maribel will ever
marry me I can't answer that son all I
can tell you is that Mirabelle is
married every World Series MVP since the
series was first contested in 1903. you
work out
coach why do you wear that funny word
looking hat nothing funny about it son
it's a cloche a coach is close it's
traditional
all right I gotta go hit something coach
you okay fella
uh you're right three more Minds broken
by baseball
we got the plunket street pushovers and
the powerful oh my God I wasn't ready
hold on
hold on
hold on
hold on
hold on good God
hold on
hold on
I'm just making this worse for myself
oh
hold on
hello
man I'm terrible at this
I feel like
a lot I feel like
I I feel like oh okay I'm either
terrible at this or
hold on hold on hold on no no hold on
hold on
coach
what's with these compasses my swing
won't connect with them I know it must
be overwhelming all I can tell you is to
stay calm and remember that in baseball
it's all about what you do hit
why is the other team getting points
when I swing
that's baseball son if the other team
ever feels physically intimidated that's
an automatic five-point penalty then how
am I supposed to win it all quit gabbing
and get back out there don't you know
leaving the field to talk to coach is a
10-point penalty
I can't seem to connect to nothing
I ain't connecting to nothing
the coach it ain't working
coach
what is going on coach
coach I don't understand
coach I don't get it
coach
[Music]
help me coach please
coach
all right I'm gonna work this out
I'm gonna work this out guys
okay wait hold on
just remember there's always other ways
to beat their score
be there's
score
oh my God God
son son my number one boy you did it you
son of a gun you won the whole damn game
did I really do good coach look at the
scoreboard it's zero to hole that's so
G coach you think Maribel will marry me
now later champ there
for that later right now you better
pucker up because here comes the coach's
big sniff
oh I love the couch is Big sniff all I
want the coaches big stuff please coach
no
oh wow he really sniffed
funny the compass feels extremely
reassuring now that it's back to being
an ordinary little thing in your hand
and not something hurl that you're
heading oversized ghostly form from
every cardinal direction it glows
faintly meat to think you were ever
scared of that little old Compass I was
never scared of the compass laugh G
coach do you think
marry me
I don't know Mark but you don't need to
call me coach we're friends call me
Jessica
[Laughter]
maybe take it easy with that machine
yeah because you call me coach and as
you know the compasses used to be
different the north used to be called
West or something all right I kind of
remember hearing about that I was only
about three years old when it happened
though ah people can get used to just
about anything nobody complains anymore
about how they stop putting lard and
chewing gum for instance
I I guess hey I found a hole in space
like a sort of shadowy pocket thing huh
you didn't put your hand in it or
anything
I absolutely stuffed my arm elbow deep
in that thing and I'll admit it to
anybody even my own mother mother you
are definitely watching this I did that
yeah there was a hot dog inside did I
eat it uh no don't answer that look I'm
gonna suggest that you don't do that
again okay
you're going to though aren't you I
guess we'll find out
open the destroyer and pokes around
inside it Charles did something to a
pair of pliers deionize them or
something I didn't catch now here they
are Shadow closing pliers
if you see any more of those things you
should be able to use these pliers to
pinch them closed without actually
touching them with your hands oh neat
thanks I'm not going to do that though
I'm not gonna do that at all
oh I need to go to the Speakeasy DNA
how's this helping finding Murray uh
detector Tron did a little little okay
whatever I didn't read that wait I got a
message
call Don t call the mob back
salutations whom is telephoning might I
inquire hi Don it's me Mark ah you
recipientated my missive commendable
yeah what's up there's an uh assignment
of which I require your performation an
assignment War I the comedic sword I
might refer to it as an uh undertaking
uh you want me to kill someone okay I'm
glad you aren't the comedic sword
there's an antiquette Distillery near
Crystal dream Lake Grandpa Joe's
Distillery to be precocious it was
abandoned when prohibitioning began
albeit with its liquor manufacturing
equipment intact a group Contra positive
to our own is claimed it as their
territory and we wish these blood
suckers to be a victorated with extreme
prejudice uh so you want me to give the
bums rush to a bunch of you're making
the bums rushed to a bunch of rival
mobgoons there is no underground
criminal organization that Rivals our
own in this vicinity when I say blood
suckers it is my intentioning that you
will observe in the phraseology a high
degree of literalness the group to which
I referenced are
Nosferatu Oh you mean actual vampires I
appear to have inadvertently voiced
another witticism
pain in Onyx well as it happens I've
already been to that Distillery and I
dealt with all the vampires well that's
a wonderment of news you anticipated the
needs of our organization and undertook
the in
initiification and to accomplish them on
your own recognitions well no I just
happened to wait I mean yes that's
exactly what I did I can plainly observe
that you will go far in this line of
vocation your payment will be delivered
to your bedroom
my payment will be delivered to my
bedroom
my why is it smoking you get a weird
feeling about it
nestled among the books and papers is in
the book of old but still valid potion
stamps with a few missing they're
surrounded by a haze of weird shadowy
energy but you can still clearly see the
illustrations of cute dogs on them wait
a minute cute dogs that's just like the
stamp that survived your luggage fire oh
dang of course that stamp is what
destroyed your luggage all your best
stuff was in there your clothes your
teddy bear that tears it the shadow
business has become personal I mean it
was personal already because Murray
being your uncle and all but now it's
extra personal a girl
these stamps these stamps have Shadow
Gunk on them and one of them killed my
luggage oh my gosh I guess that was my
fault I ran out of stamps and found
those inside Murray's desk I didn't even
think to protest them I'm so sorry it's
not your fault it's whatever was causing
this damn Shadow stuff I'm definitely
gonna put a stop to it though wait how
many of these stamps have you used just
one thankfully the rest must have been
gone when Murray found him well that's
good news at least I think anyway I'm
gonna go drop off this at uh
thumperdinck's drink
following me like that you weirdo
sup boys thanks Boys Hey fancy Dan
I get money oh my God Mark streamer
Ariat look this is just what I do
because if I had to re if I had to
record this and then edit it and then
upload it it would take so much time and
then it would be even longer before I
was able to actually do any of this I
don't feel like doing that I found a
case of rum I found a case of gin
okay there you go
no I've got the heck of Soto okay here
comes
I'm okay
I'm all right
I'm okay
what about lixian uh
look I had to fire
[Laughter]
look it's it's streamer ERA this is all
I do now so I just I can't possibly do
any of that and therefore I'm
it's over
over I got some applicants for the new
storefront I fixed up over there on the
other side of Colo Wars Surplus Store
got a second to pick one sure the first
applicant is 10 Things I had about you a
hat store I presume thinking is rodkins
fine jewelry a jewelry store uh let's go
with the hat store despite the name
okay I'll get it moved in oh
put the crystal
gave you on the Shelf is that clear oh
all right take a look
rub the crystal
I got twinkling
[Music]
how am I doing I'm doing great
oh
mock the quality of your work at The
Distillery has been noted as excellent
we will continue we will contact you in
a telephone manner with further
opportunities DT Briefcase full of meat
how much meat
well I mean I did it anyway so whatever
guys I can't bring back lixian I'm sorry
it's just
likes have been down
recently likes shares they've been down
Shares are really low this month so
I pay Lexi and purely on shares and
likes and without them I just can't
keep them around
I'm sorry it's just like
that's just the way it is without those
likes without those shares without
people adding things to their favorites
look lyxian just had to go
and there's there's really nothing that
we could do I mean I guess everyone
could click the like button and that
might bring lyxian back but it would
have to be a lot and a lot of shares too
and a lot of a lot of uh
this dude
oh man I guys you you are not making my
80d any better by um I forgot this guy
was here by uh constantly distracting me
from what I'm trying to do I'm uh I'm
really trying to keep this flowing and
keep this moving properly and uh I'm oh
it's a dream
relaxed and another fitful dream if you
repeated enough times it starts to sound
like a real word
does it
does it that does doesn't does it does
it does it does it sound like a real
word
here in this land of dreams
would miss the Museum of skulls
wait a minute
one of these skulls is yours
and this is my fingers teeth
would you recognize her own skull if you
saw it in a dream
good morning
what would you want
to give it the one the one to carry
back
thank you but you have no time
you're not sure what this is but you're
sure what it isn't curious
change conversation is taking place here
I will participate the women's cows in
you
good news
but hog Futures are up 10 points
everything is just pgking Keen not a
president
the damn project is complete
it doesn't mean
you recognize you if you were me and I
were you
I don't think so
everything's perfect man the circuits
are lit up just like a criminal tree
what about them
yes I'm working on that a little bird
has told me his last name
yeah
if you can believe
my friends Morris
any relative of Murray Morris is an
enemy of ours find him
guided man
both Noel and the president of wing out
of existence with an ominous sounding
pop
you are ready for this dream to be over
and how
[Music]
that's what I that's what I get I look
over and I just see I just [ __ ] my pants
[Laughter]
I swear to God every time I look over at
something even worse
me better anymore if I'm really
I don't think there's any way to make
this any better but alas
we find a doorway back to the waking
world and it's time to step through
oh you're on Aroma what a dream
what a dream that was great
[Laughter]
everybody like oh shut my pie I just
[ __ ] my pants I'm gonna [ __ ] your pants
that's my favorite edit meme of me it's
just me on uh
God Kingpin from spider-verse
and just like I'm gonna [ __ ] yourself
[Laughter]
this kiss me every time I don't know
what it is about that
yeah anyway save elixion I don't think
it's possible guys I don't think it's
possible there's no way I've I actually
already forgot about what
huh
morning Mark how are you feeling I'm
fine I guess I've been having weird
dreams oh like well one where you're
driving a car but you're in the back
seat and can't reach controls I can't
remember very clearly but I think it was
weirder than that I really hate that one
anyway I found the next curse thing it's
a hardcover book and yeah big and it's
somewhere on the campus of the seaside
Institute of Technology in porkum you
ready to go I haven't even had coffee
yet I'm sure you'll be able to find some
coffee when you get there they've
probably invented some kind of
high-powered science coffee or something
all right all right do you have a map of
the place no but it's a college campus
it can't be that hard to find your way
around college students do it all day
the bus to porkum leaves from the usual
stuff good luck thank you I guess hey
look a message
call Don t
Don Toblerone verbalizing a Don it's me
asplundiferous Kudos on your triumphial
completion of my previous assignment a
signation
you're welcome is that all in fact I
have another item in business to be
attenuated which I believe to be suited
marvelously to one of your skills which
one no I mean well regardlessly we
require that you proceed to a pace to
Crystal dream Lake whereas is located a
purveyor of tools and Implements of
construction say again you might
vernaculize it as a hardware store ah
you guys running out of cement or
something
we have a necessary tool that you will
perform upon this place of business that
we will categorize as a Shakedown there
you meet no we are merely desirous that
the local commercialists retail Emporia
feel a measure of our intimidation
okay I guess I can handle that
I don't know why I need to intimidate
the poor person but that's
fine how do you turn the quality up I
have no idea I have no idea at all
oh
all right let me go I need to go back uh
do I go to the um
I do get some money if I go here but why
would I want to I like the guy at the
hardware store why would I want to shake
him down
why would I want clicky Dem settings hey
you guys got this sorted you guys tell
me how to do that oh frick I should pay
my back you stroll up to yourself and
hand them 300 meat as expected he's a
bit puzzled by this here take this meat
technically I guess I should be repaying
it to the Future me but that's me now so
you'll have to do it but what's the
point in giving me meat if I have to
give it back to me later you'll be
making me more easily later
so this won't seem like as much then
just think of it as a no interest loan
on the contrary I actually am interested
roll your eyes God what a cornball joke
you're frankly embarrassed to have made
it uh yeah anyway don't forget to pay
you back with the universe will explode
or something it probably wouldn't but it
probably would
the quality's too loud and we've come
full circle back to the other jokes
bring lixian mark back Mark all right
fine I'll do it bring him back not oh
you guys thought it'd be that easy no no
propose a shaking I've been asked to
shake up some of your merchandise come
again there's some mob guys who want to
intimidate you for some reason so they
sent me here to shake things up or down
something like that huh well those cans
of pain over there could use a good
shaking it ain't got around to it for a
while okay sounds good can't say I feel
it particularly intimidated though
uh
paint shake them up you give all the
pains cans of vigorous shaking the
proprietor to nods is thanks
all right
I did it
I I did it did I did I did it
did did I did it
did I did it oh
no wait wait a minute wait wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute drawer
okay cool wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute everybody wait a minute everybody
hold on everybody hold on everybody wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute are you waiting are you waiting
you better wait you better wait you
better wait wait I'm gonna shake it down
oh oh Outhouse rentals what
can I rent the last one sure thing it'll
be 200 meat up front for the
installation half each month afterwards
what maintenance do you do I dumped some
powered lime down the whole clean out
the ventilation check for splinters and
once the pit starts to get full I'll
move the Outhouse over a couple of yards
and dig a new one for you plus get a
free subscription
I don't why did I just
put it in the cave what
huh
let's see what
okay
you must mean the bait shop love that
sense of humor you got pet worms
whatever what is outhouse
wait a minute
but
what
I was not confused
I'm so confused
click the Amber I'm so confused I'm so
confused
have you seen that Outhouse around here
have you seen that outhouse
oh
oh
great hi hi and welcome to Grady's live
bait I'm Grady and this is my bait shop
anything you need help with well I'm
always looking for people to dig up
night crawlers for me what are
Nightcrawlers he pulls out a handful of
wriggling worms then he waves your face
God worms you will never forget the
smell interested in doing some worm
hunting
sure I'll get you some gross worms good
deal dig up oh let's call it five five
good size night crawlers and I'll make
it worth your while here you'll need
this yeah yeah just follow your nose you
want another whiff to refresh your
memory he starts to reach under the
cover again no no no no no no I got it
where do I oh
dig
great I got a plump one
good I got one
I got one so far
good
[Music]
Gray
are they everywhere do I have to go
everywhere for them
huh
I'll get the hot picks in a second you
will wait you will wait patiently I'm
putting you in timeout anybody that ever
misses a photographer again you are
going in timeout I am well aware of the
Hat photographer and you will wait
patiently for it
anywho
I'm gonna move this
fight
is that's a big shroom
are you all afraid
you should be afraid you should have
been more afraid before but you weren't
because you don't even understand what
it means to be afraid I will show you
the meaning of fear I
I will show you something all right
whatever
I
don't know why I decided to get on this
side quest when I have so many other
things to do so what I think I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna back out and I'm going
to go to the college campus
actually what I'm probably gonna do wait
what time is it
ah interesting
interesting
interesting hold on everybody hold that
thought hold that thought
hold that thought
and try to keep it in your mind
God damn why did I get in the middle of
the fight
oh stench does nothing to that thing
oh it's got so much health
okay hold on
hold on that's not good
physical damage
there we go and you
almost okay hold on no your thoughts are
too loud yes quiet your thoughts
[Music]
okay
so
I think
I've got time
I've got time hey why don't we just
chill why don't we just hang out this is
gonna really mess with people that are
that are uh
in watching this in the future because
if it's gonna be like it's not there but
I'm kind of curious did you guys know
that I crashed my bike that's why my
elbow that is blood I got my knee all
banged up I did that
um but I just want to hang out and chat
a little bit because I actually I don't
have time to get into something and I
have to go soon but all right see how
are you guys doing what's up with you
how are you are you good what the [ __ ]
oh my God yes I'm fine is my eye still
bloody
like right here this is still bloody I
have no idea yeah I got my knee all
blessed up it was raining over here so I
I skidded my bike and I dumped it I was
trying to avoid uh there was this nice
lady walking her dog and I was I was
turning to avoid it and I it was on a
slanted the road was wet so I just kind
of went and there we go
so sir I also hurt my hip
hurt my hip you're playing sea of
Thieves right now how are you doing this
tired but managing yeah I've actually
been pretty good uh not to be rude about
being like yeah no I haven't been tired
I don't even know the meaning of tired
no I just been sleeping good which been
very very nice I've been like sleeping
super good super super good why is it no
okay it's Sunday I was like you someone
said member mixer and I was like did I
miss it did I miss it no I didn't miss
it I didn't miss it at all
hypersomnia what the hell is that is
that too much sleep
hope I heal up soon oh I'm sure I'm
gonna heal back just fine I'm gonna heal
back no problem at all this everything's
fine I really I literally thought it was
Monday for a second
I really did I really did yeah no it's
been very good
I look the title is what the title is
there's really nothing I can do about
the title it simply is uh and there's
nothing to be done about it it just is
and we're not gonna worry about it very
much we're not gonna worry at all
to worry at all did you guys have a good
New Year I didn't ask anybody did you
guys have a good Christmas holiday
season all that stuff
Martin Luther King Jr is tomorrow is it
I have totally forgot about
that I really didn't know about that
is the stream over no I'm talking to you
guys can't a guy just talk can't a guy
scream at his audience every once in a
while candy guy just share off some
random ramblings from inside of their
mind which is what I'm going to be doing
yes
good good good good good good back to
school
continue talking I will
can't really stop me I just talk all the
time anyway
I wish you a quick regeneration that is
a weird way to say
wishing someone healed quickly that is
very weird but I guess it's correct
because I am going to regenerate these
skin cells I guess that's bizarre
Justice for elixir
you guys seem to have a misconception of
what actually is happening there
see lexian is uh in prison
but it's not like a government prison
it's more of a prison of the mind I've
trapped him within many layers of his
own mind so that he has to solve The
Riddles of his past and overcome his
personal demons to be able to escape
really I'm doing him a service so it's
not really Injustice it's sort of like
hooray for elixion
he is spiraling in his own inner Madness
but if he makes it out which he probably
will he probably will I I believe in him
that he'll he'll be stronger for it you
know what I mean he'll be stronger for
it
so that's what really matters so that's
good yes I was chicken Andrew chicken
Henry very good they're very very good
I'm very very uh
very very happy that they are back home
or they are very happy that they're not
in the car anymore because that was a
quite a drive yeah it was a very very
interesting Drive yeah
how was good girl chicken how are
chica's legs uh I haven't seen chica's
legs in a while but I'm assuming that
they're okay wherever they are so that's
good
company paid training I don't know oh
you're doing company paid training I was
like what company do we have here Ohio
is the best state that's an interesting
uh interesting thing to say
that's interesting
lyxian crashed my bike for me
yeah fair enough yeah fair enough
how's Amy Amy's good Amy good her legs
are gone I don't think they ever said
nobody ever said anything about
chica's legs being gone it's just kind
of a lack of knowledge of wherever they
are and that's very different right
that's a different thing you know what I
mean that's that's different that's very
different very very different indeed
yeah
you crashed your mark I don't know
Markiplier the movie I need to know uh
well you won't know anything but you
will know things very soon about it
um So eventually you will be able to
hear more things about it in the movie
that I'm making
um but we are going to come up with a
big old plan for world domination that
I'm gonna need all of your help with
because that's what we do here at
Markiplier HQ we make sure that we do
our best to take over the world in
whatever way we can
it's all a concerted effort to be able
to achieve that
threshold of success that we all measure
in terms of how many theaters we can get
into or whatever it is anyway I'm making
a movie just because I want to make a
movie
um after getting done with space
I discovered that making in space with
markiplier is so much more intricate and
difficult than just making a movie it's
not like making a movie is easy
but the amount of work that I put into
making in space with markiplier was
orders of magnitude more than the work
that I would put into making a movie and
so I decided to relax and take it Easy
by making a movie I know people can look
at this be like whoa this is so
incredible it's like
um but no I'm gonna make a movie and
it'll be very fun I think you guys are
gonna really like it I I cannot wait to
start selling you guys about it like
giving you a little bit it's not the
Five Nights at Freddy's movie I am not
allowed to make the Five Nights at
Freddy's movie I can tell you that
straight up because it's not my property
and they definitely would not trust me
to do that I'm not saying I wouldn't do
a great job if I was trusted to do the
Five Nights at Freddy's movie I bet I
would do a pretty good job because I
would like try really hard at and yada
yada but I wouldn't want to really do it
anyway because there's just like so many
expectation and like well no actually
okay if I was offered I would say yes
absolutely and then I would do it so I
can't really say I wouldn't want to do
it because if I was offered I would do
it so but I'm not so it's a moot point
no matter what
yeah
yeah
the continuation of lore news story I'm
not gonna make a new story why would you
make a new story that's like all the the
different adaptations that the other
streamers doing is like why trust any of
the swoosh material we gotta come up
with something new there and there's
adaptations to be made of sure of course
things need to be adapted it can't be
the same exact story as like the game is
it's got to be in a different format
it's a movie but the problem with
adaptations is that they don't do
anything this faithful to the original
story while transforming it over to a
new median
yeah so it's a little bit more difficult
yeah
oh yeah I did get a boo-boo on my finger
um
no it's now guys don't guess anything
about it you'll know more about the
movie uh when it's time to talk about
the movie but until then it's just
talking about life and getting back into
the swing of things with making content
here on the good old YouTube I have
Ambitions and I have things that I want
to do well like outside of YouTube in
terms of like making high production
quality stuff
but always like what one of the things
that I want to do this year is just get
back into regular making all regular
content I'm so tired of like I get busy
and then my upload schedule gets all
wonky and then I'm not making videos I'm
not talking to you guys and I'm not
having fun and I'm not just doing these
things I mean I'm having fun doing all
these other big projects but it's like
this is like this is what it's all about
it's just making videos here making
content here so I never want to forget
that yeah where will the movie be seen I
will ideally in a theater near you but
you know that's harder that's easier
said than done so we'll see about that
yeah give you a drink I'm not going to
give you a drink I can't give you
anything this is the internet
what is my hair routine I wash it and
I'm lucky that I wash it that's my hair
routine yeah and bust a movie and very
funny very funny yeah
uh
only fans oh yeah the third drop for
only fans will come eventually I I just
haven't got around to it
low-key flexing on what my movie making
ability well you'll see when you see it
so I'm not gonna Flex on that but I'm
very excited for it and I think you guys
will like it oh I do got to play Oxygen
not included oh what I want to do what I
wanted to say also is with this uh game
with um shadows overloathing and
Callisto protocol and
the other one
oh bendy bendy bendy and the the dark
Revival I want to just get those done
quicker so I might do another live
stream of Callisto protocol or I might
just record it with the idea that it's
just going to be uploaded but it's like
I gotta get all these done because I
can't let these all three of these just
end in the middle of the series like I
meant to do it a lot sooner and I meant
to record it beforehand but at the same
time I'm just like God it just takes so
much time to play these games but I got
other things that I want to do so I'm
going to get them done and I'm probably
gonna Reserve more time to do another
stream like this where I can just play
through it and goof around with it and
that way it can be done and I don't have
to worry about trying to edit it and
uploading it I can just like doing it
we'll do it in a big stream we might
just make like a 12 hour day of it and
just play all of it who knows maybe we
could do that and yeah the glitched
attraction I know but I didn't exactly
end that in like a middle I can wait
I'll I'll get to that don't worry yeah
glitch attract can get shut up shut shut
your face hole shut up no game
suggestions
why are people like Finnish bendy and
I'm like I just said yes that's what I'm
doing why do you know guys not listen to
me when I speak
listen to me
good
good tiny out of your ears and listen
anyway Skyrim okay I'm not gonna finish
Skyrim there are many games that I've
started and I have not finished that I'm
not going to go back to but these three
is what I'm gonna do so I'm gonna get
them I'm gonna get them I'm definitely
gonna get them and speaking of add I do
want to eventually make that video
talking about my experiences with ADD
but I have not been able to like do it
to a level where I feel confident in
what I'm talking about because I'm not
an expert I'm not a psychiatrist I don't
have a degree in any of this stuff so
I'd just be talking from experience but
I also don't want to just talk out my
ass and stuff like that so I've got
plenty of
plenty of things that I want to do
plenty of things that I want to do
eventually and I will do them but for
now
I've chewed up all the time that I have
so thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you for joining me on
this wonderful stream on this wonderful
day I hope you all have a fantastic
evening I hope you all have a wonderful
time
and I will see you in the very near
future with much much more fun fun stuff
to watch and play together
real soon
remember Booboo kisses for everyone all
around there I've got boo-boos and I
need many boo-boo kisses so thank you
everybody so much for being here I will
see you tomorrow
with much more sweet delicious
content for you to consume thank you
farewell goodbye